more money could soon be available to
help out struggling businesses and
non-profits amid covet
the nevada assembly fast tracking a bill
that would put
50 million more dollars into a pandemic
grant program
that is called pets orco mana joining us
live with
what could happen with that funding orco
well brian it's important to note that
the pets grant website says
applications are currently not being
accepted anymore but small businesses
and nonprofits who have already applied
and were denied
could get up to ten thousand dollars
we took a hit by having to reduce staff
in some areas
like many nevada small businesses sonia
pedowick's consulting company has been
crippled by coven 19.
she applied for the pandemic emergency
technical support or pets grant last
fall to get help
i met all of the qualifications as
outlined in the portal
but with so many asking for aid the
money just wasn't there
now there's hope the nevada assembly
unanimously passing a bill wednesday
night to put 50 million more dollars
into the program pedowick
praying she gets the funding i'd love to
put it back into workforce right and be
able to hire back
staff and talent offset some of my
overhead costs would be
you know a blessing governor steve
sisolak has asked state lawmakers to
prioritize the pets grant as it already
helped thousands across the state for
many of our small businesses the funding
they were provided was a difference
between staying open or closing their
doors the same goes for non-profits such
as united citizens foundation which
provides mental health services to kids
and families
staff say the money made a difference
the pets grant allowed us to fill in
fill
in that gap to be able to see some kids
that did not have a pay source that did
not have insurance
those in limbo right now can only do one
thing i'm
waiting and being as patient as i can
the bill now goes to the nevada senate
if approved all funds must be
distributed
by june 30. reporting live tonight orco
mana 8 news now